ça passait me faire passer le message un
mantra répéter aux quatre coins du web
aujourd'hui
moi j'ai un compte instagram qui est
majoritairement suivie par des
milléniaux par des gens fait que je
pense que tant qu'à monde qui nous
suivent aussi bien de passer le message
donc aujourd'hui je réponds à l'appel de
mon beau frère françois legault promu
nice du québec
le premier ministre veut éviter que
circule ce genre d'invitation à des
parts et pour les braves seulement
première main japon étaient invités se
sentent interpellés juge pas la seule
puis je sue ben heureuse de voir que
yann barthès qu'il prenne au sérieux ce
c'est que tu n'es pas à risque et que tu
veux voir des amis mais si tu fais des
gens faut mourir
comme vous nous les jacks et les jeunes
écoutent
bonjour et au monastère tingwick qui je
me suis dit mais pourquoi pas tourner
sans un peu en chansons
[Musique]
je les eaux
si important que le gouvernement compte
lancer une campagne de sensibilisation
sur le web
la campagne va s'appeler propager l'info
statut je me reprends propage l'info
paul virus propage l'info paul virus je
les salue monsieur l'avait voulu mais un
véritable mouvement pour éviter la
propagation de la coved 19 mai faut
vraiment rester à la maison
ça fait quand même quelque chose de ce
fait divers vous est important c'est
c'est plutôt raconte rien au sérieux
pour des enjeux sociaux d une occasion
de se servir de sa tribune pas pour des
mentions j'aime mais pour sauver des
vies qu ici sébastien desrosiers
radio-canada moyens